happy happy New Years a lot
[Laughter]
um
what this is the new president and vice
president of the Philippines doing a
YouTube q a months before their
Landslide election Victory we will
answer anything that you asked all right
game game
Ferdinand Marcos Jr known as bongbong
shares the same name as his father the
notorious autocrat who led a military
government in the Philippines which
tortured and killed thousands of
citizens while he and his family stole
billions from the public purse
but none of that stopped bongbong Marcos
winning this year's election the people
have spoken they have given Marcus a
resounding victory Marcus won by a
landslide he got almost 59 of the votes
this was an epic win the days after the
election friends and colleagues from
pretty much everywhere ask me
how could this happen
using the power of social media Marcos
his election team and supporters have
Rewritten history claiming his father's
era was a time of prosperity and
strength rather than murder and theft on
an industrial scale
it's frustrating for us because all this
time we have been debunking the
disinformation the lies that helped him
win this election but the people still
ended up choosing the lies please
subscribe to us the way that social
media was utilized even weaponized
should serve as a warning around the
world I guess for the journalists and
fact Checkers in other countries where
this could possibly happen as well I
wish you good luck
foreign
[Music]
was released in 2007 just under six
percent of the Philippines was on the
web but smartphones changed that
now two-thirds of the country's 110
million citizens are connected and spend
10 hours a day online that's more than
any other country
[Music]
you can just imagine how much time we
spend here on social media even here
walking on the street you can see people
looking down on their phones not looking
on the road and then according to the
data we use social media to gather
information including the news and at
the same time to connect to people so
it's really our main source of
information here in the Philippines
Filipinos spend more than four hours a
day on social media with Facebook being
the most popular platform with nearly 84
million users in 2022
a survey here recently showed that more
than half of the people who said that
they're using social media as their news
source find it very difficult to
distinguish between what's true and
what's false on social media so uh you
can just imagine the extent of that
problem
the 2018 Cambridge analytica Scandal saw
the data mining firm questioned over its
work for Donald Trump's presidential
campaign
one whistleblower described how
questionable rule of law high social
media usage and corrupt politicians made
the Philippines the perfect place to
test the limits of online manipulation
at some point we were called patient
zero when it comes to this information
brexit the election that Trump won these
are also events that showcased how much
social media use can shape public
opinion but this time around it's really
supercharged
there's a feeling that it's been well
structured institutionalized it really
shows that you can win an election based
on an image you have built on social
media
bongbong Marcos has been building his
online presence for over a decade during
his unsuccessful 2016 run for vice
president he relied heavily on online
messaging
these 2022 campaign he sized up
traditional media instead speaking
directly to voters online in short video
blogs he gets a lot of engagements for
that and a lot of people like that about
him the Vlog thing they really patronize
that because I guess it humanizes him
I've seen analysis on social media
saying that he intentionally did not
attend debates and interviews because
that was what contributed to his loss in
2016 so there was a revisiting of the
strategy the campaign strategy and as we
are able to see now we could say that it
has been effective
Facebooks and YouTube's Instagram
Twitter
bongbong has over 7 million followers on
Facebook and another 2 million on
YouTube his supporters flood news feeds
and message boards with election
messages
[Music]
but political posts and videos are often
disguised
a lot of the disinformation that
spreading on social media especially in
the lead up to the elections come in the
form of news some are quoting
personalities
inaccurately but are presented in such a
way that they look like and even imitate
the colors of mainstream media we found
out that out of the 300 plus fact checks
that we produced for online
disinformation
120 of them has something to do with
election related disinformation and a
huge number of that actually benefited
Marcos in a way that it hyped up his
presidential campaign and it also tried
to distort historical facts regarding
his family
[Music]
in the 1970s Ferdinand Marcos had led a
military government of uncommon
brutality
he disbanded Congress silenced the media
and used the Army to torture and kill
thousands of citizens
through all of this Marcos and his wife
Imelda became exceedingly Wealthy by
siphoning money from State funds
all the while the Philippines economy
crashed and many people suffered
[Music]
a critical part of bongbong marcos's
election campaign was convincing
millions of people these things simply
didn't happen
foreign
the pure hate that has been heaped upon
him over the last 30 plus years
his memory his legacy continues to
endure
it was portrayed by their supporters as
a period of prosperity despite economic
downturn that time and then it was also
portrayed that only enemies of the state
were killed extravagant parties on the
presidential yacht and then also um
there was a widespread denial about the
ill-gotten wealth Ferdinand Jr is the
man in the flashing bow tie and this
circulated mostly in social media and
that Legacy was the one that Ferdinand
Marcos Jr in their own words they tried
to present their version of that history
and that's what people are gonna believe
the love for the Marcus has never really
left here in the Philippines even after
they were ousted they maintained uh
quite a strong Bailey week in the
northern Philippines and that's where
the most loyal supporters are so this
effort to explain their side of History
became even more evident because of
social media that even went into
overdrive because of the pandemic when
people were stuck at home
social media when I talk to people and
ask them who they were inclined to
support if they said bongbong Marcos I
would say why and there would be this
Gauzy look in these sentiments expressed
like you know his father was a great man
he was a strong leader Philippines need
strong leadership now
and you would say okay well what about
this what about that what about the
other thing and they would blow it off
the response would tend to be one of two
things they would say oh look I was a
kid then or I wasn't born then it's
nothing to me
or they say it's fake news
tonight a brutal dictator's son winning
the presidential election in the
Philippines by a landslide
Marcos has been elected as the next
president of the Philippines and I think
that's a very telling indication as to
how successful this this information
campaign benefiting him is God bless the
Philippines God bless our work
the days after the election friends and
colleagues asked me
how could this happen
then I began to wonder whether the more
pertinent question was what was actually
going to stop it
it's hard to overstate how much online
disinformation propelled the success of
bongbong's campaign
but directly connecting social media
lies to their sources let alone anyone
directing the effort remains difficult
you have supporters real people and then
on the other hand you have fake accounts
and these fake accounts plus the real
people who are spreading this that
creates an ecosystem wherein this
information spreads
we're able to Monitor and flag these
online disinformation content but we
really cannot pinpoint who is the person
or the person but one thing I could tell
you is President bongbong Marcos he
likes to disassociate himself and his
team from this information campaign that
largely benefited him in fact he even
said that he's actually the victim of
fake news some people say that history
was revised online what do you what is
your response to that show me
show me where this revisionism well now
are part from our side whatever you want
to show me
uh anything that we have said we can
prove
the success of boom booms campaign can't
solely be attributed to social media
another major factor was the effect of
his running mate Sarah duterte daughter
of the previous president Rodrigo
duterte who remains popular in parts of
the Philippines this time around with
Sarah duterte running by his side he was
able to win those provinces in the
southern part of the country where the
duterte's hail from and he was able to
double the number of provinces that he
was able to win compared to his 2016
vice presidential race which he lost
it's really a consolidation of two
powerful political dynasties political
families one healing from the north
that's Marcos and the other hailing from
the south and that's duterte
the Philippines excels at dynastic
Politics the two presidents prior to
leader Rodrigo duterte they were
children of presidents
the lower House of our Congress we have
a majority and most of our lawmakers are
products of political dynasties there's
even a belief that the good traits the
leadership qualities of a father or a
parent is passed down to his or her
child so that's how much political
dynasties are welcomed and elected here
in the Philippines
while Marcos and duterte ran on a ticket
of national Unity online their
supporters pushed lies and attacked the
opposition candidate Lenny robredo
you would tend to say that we shouldn't
focus on the negative things and instead
focus on unity and nation building so
that's the official line but on Facebook
on social media you can see how much
vitriol there was especially against his
main opponent vice president Lenny
robredo Roberto has been called so many
names she was even accused of having an
affair her daughters were accused of
having sex scandals a lot of these
Facebook pages and Facebook groups that
were able to flag spreading this
information and misinformation some of
them carry his name in their account
names
um and we actually also observed and
back in 2021 that a lot of YouTube
videos that are misinforming people what
happens is um the video is uploaded on
YouTube and then there are a number of
Facebook pages that re-uploads it on
Facebook that also re-uploaded on tiktok
and this suggests that there is
automation or that only one person
administers or moderates these accounts
and so it also suggests that there is a
an organized effort or campaign with
regards to
um spreading Miss and disinformation
my father built more and better roads
produced more rice than all
administrations before his
so will it be with his son you will get
no excuses from me
now as president bongbong Marcos bashens
himself as a pragmatist focused on
quality of life issues
on foreign policy he's promised to grow
closer relations with China even as the
two countries Clash over fishing rights
in the South China Sea
all the while maintaining historic links
to the USA
this idea or this feeling or this
shall we say opinion I have of my father
of the man
has just been strengthened as time goes
on what's also noteworthy is bongbong
never talked about marcelona in a
negative light it's all about admiration
for his father a promise to continue the
good projects that came out of that era
it's really an indication that you can
win an election based on a particular
image that you shaped on social media
for some there is frustration that lies
have won over facts but there's also
concern that things will only get worse
over the course of this six-year
presidential term the facts of the past
is not really as effective as the facts
of the present and the future maybe it's
because the people now cannot relate
with whatever happened during the
martial law of Marco senior and they
actually only care about what's going to
happen to them now and what's going to
happen in the future and Marcus Jr
apparently was able to present himself
effectively as someone who will bring
about positive change who will bring
hope and who will unify the country
towards a better tomorrow or a better
future
if you're gonna get a platform like
social media that reaches a lot of
people you're gonna create a way by
which this version of history is going
to spread and your supporters are gonna
spread and believe it
Imelda Marcos famously said in one of
the documentaries about her perception
is real and the truth is not
our job as fact Checkers and not only
fact Checkers but as journalists as
amplifiers of truth would be more
challenging in the next
um six years because we see the election
of a president whose campaign was based
on this information and lies so we have
to be ready for the challenges that this
Administration would entail so yeah
um we're we're preparing for it and
hopefully we could go through it
um without any problem
foreign
[Music]
[Music]